you guys want to hear Gary's greatest
blunders absolutely this is just a list
of Gary's mistakes from the last year
and there were a lot but I'll play just
the big one do we have enough time
supposed to be the highlight to me the
biggest fuck-up Gary had in 2018 was the
Cobra Kai incident and it really still
bothers me to this I you know there are
certain shows that come in to us because
they're sent and they send them to Gary
and and and I say this with all due
respect they're really sending him to me
they don't want Gary to watch it they
want me I'm the guy on the air they want
me to see Cobra Kai so Gary gets an
advanced copy of The Karate Kid TV show
Cobra Kai doesn't even tell me about it
and then I bring it up in the news yeah
I thought the whole thing to know I love
karate kid can't watch it man what other
things do you get that you don't tell me
about I don't know I said they have the
guys on the show that's the only reason
we got it both carotids he did was
really good but you're you're you're a
guy come in contact who are the other
people got it i think steve god I can't
believe Steve Brandon oh yes Steve he
sees it and I don't give me the option
send it to Laura hello I mean seriously
what on what planet what was that on
Amazon no it was it was uh YouTube Bret
YouTube red wants me to see you mean to
tell me they didn't notice happy for me
they sent it to us because the guy was
on the wrap-up show yeah I'm just saying
that's why they sent none of you guys go
hey Howard likes Karate Kid we didn't
think you would like it because we
didn't know we didn't know what you were
like once you just ask me
did we do this already Steve brand
Donald gets a copy of it well he's the
producer the rapper oh excuse me I'm the
[ __ ] guy I'm just explaining I'm not
saying you weren't explained you were
throwing them under the bus we were
talking about how crazy you know this is
not a good category just gets me crazy
why should you be reminded of these I
didn't write this I didn't bring this in
all right my idea so we're on the air
and we're talking about radio station
call letters and I mentioned to Robin
that one www in Detroit they were the
worst call letters because he like at
the top the area to go wwww for it was
just [ __ ] wordy and it's an ya wasn't
cool like in a www is not a cool letter
so Gary comes out of nowhere and you go
and he just interrupts and he's telling
me how KO and me in San Jose also had
shitty call letters and how was I just
erupted because ko and me was like the
greatest call lives I only wish I
couldn't work for K ome come radio it
was the coolest [ __ ] thing ever I
thought the other bed all letters that
was a station that we were on and San
Jose was ko Emmy that's great come radio
that was like a whole sexual double
entendre it would say stupid [ __ ] like
here's another come shot yeah why is
that stupid I know I thought it was dog
get out of here wwww is dumb comm is
Ronnie I didn't bring up when we
remodeled the you know we renovated the
studio in 2017 and I was accepting my
hair award you know my best hair award
and I asked Gary where my previous
awards were have I actually ever
accepted like have you given me those
awards absolutely Gary where is the time
displayed we have where is my hair award
I think what trophy case
the studio has changed dairy had no
ideas of studio change this concerns me
their right to the right of you where
are my awards have you thrown your
awards away well you know gary said
during some sort of storage facility I
believe it's a called a garbage pail
yeah he knows we moved from k-rock you
probably still things were in that's
that was a bad [ __ ] you clearly didn't
know that we had renovated of course I
knew and I just I mean it's you know my
reflex reaction was just over they were
there
I knew we remodeled the studio anyway I
don't want to review every one of Gary's
fuck-ups we'd be here told 2020